Now let's turn our attention to Auditing Accuracy. As I
mentioned in the overview, this is something that is difficult to
do in a lot of situations because it requires gold
standard data. Let's take a look at our city's info box
data set for an example. Returning to the Hyderabad wikipedia
page. If we scroll down, we can see that country is
one of the fields that's included in the info box
data for this, and for most countries in this data set.
Now it's possible in our data that the countries specified
for a city isn't actually a valid country for one
reason or another. So in order to audit this country
field for accuracy, we're going to need some means of programmatically
processing it and comparing and the values that we find
to some set of data that we can reliably assume is
correct. So, the gold standard data that I'm going to use
here is some country code data from the ISO. The International
Standards Organization. This is data that pairs a two digit country
code with a country name. So in order to verify these country
codes, we're essentially going to do a look up of each name
we find in this list of country names we can rely on.